the family of a black man killed by
Minneapolis police is demanding justice
after prosecutors decided not to charge
the two officers who shot him
police say body cam video shows Thurman
Blevins had a gun and refused orders to
stop and show his hands last month but
Levin's family and supporters say he did
not pose a threat
yesterday they shouted down the
prosecutor announcing that the officer's
actions were justified vladimir duthiers
of our streaming network cbsn shows us
what's behind the tensions flag good
morning good morning police say the
officers received a 9-1-1 call that
Blevins had a gun and was shooting into
the air now prosecutors say body cam
footage proves their version of events
but it also has the community
questioning whether the officers needed
to shoot police body cam footage shows
the moment officers Justin Schmidt and
Ryan Kelly confronted Thurman Blevins
you can hear Blevins begging officers
not to shoot just a few seconds later
they opened fire 14 times four of those
shots hit Blevins he died on the scene
in order to bring charges against a
police officer the state must be able to
prove beyond a reasonable doubt that the
officers use of deadly force was not
authorized Hennepin County Attorney Mike
Freeman cleared officer Schmidt and
Kelly from wrongdoing Monday he claims
Blevins disregard for police
instructions and his allegedly pointing
a gun at officers justified the shooting
uncertain and rapidly evolving
situations but as Freeman made his
announcement Blevins family and
community activists shouted him down
they claim Blevins was not a threat and
accused officers of escalating the
situation these officers was not afraid
of my cousin when they approached him
that's clear as day on the video footage
did you see a drunk black guy
the Minneapolis community is still
grappling with recent deadly shootings
of unarmed black men falando Castillo
and Jamar Clark no officers were found
guilty in either incident but following
the release of this new footage the head
of the police union called these
officer's actions heroic the officers
deserved the Minneapolis Police
Department's highest award the Medal of
Honor both officers are still on paid
leave and an internal investigation is
underway that will determine if the
officers will be put back on active duty
the family still wants both officers to
be arrested and charged within 48 hours
and to be fired from the Minneapolis
Police Department they say there will be
consequences if those demands are not
met Nora all right Vlad thank you